i don't feel like an actor
i don't feel
what i think an actor should feel like
which is in control
and and
and happy
you know doing it yeah is that what you
saw your leads and tammy faye doing it
breathing yeah
when you're
at that level when you're a great actor
and it doesn't you don't have to be that
kind of actor you could be
a comic actor you can there's there's
any you could be a soap opera actor
doesn't matter yeah but it's that
feeling that like i'm i'm me right now
i'm and when i'm directing and this
feels sort of like goofy to even say but
i feel that way i feel like completely
in my own skin i feel very confident in
i don't feel the need to pop pose or
posture or anything i
am more than happy to say if i don't
know uh
what something is could you you know the
ad or someone will say like oh we need a
something or other
thing and i'm like what's that what do
you think about yeah i don't need to
know it all i don't need i just but i do
feel like there's something that i have
to offer and it's unique
and um
and you know i really felt that way as
an actor i love that i love i'm just
happy for you just as a human person
because
finding those spots where you're fully
yourself huge relationships where you're
full of yourself jobs where you're
feeling everything it's it's literally
authenticity yes authenticity and is
that what andrew and jessica you saw
them i have to imagine so they just um
they're different they have both of them
have a different process they're both
very very well researched so they both
do an incredible amount of reading and
research and and they think a lot about
their characters and they talk to people
that knew i mean they they all that
stuff i mean they treat it
you know
they have they they they take it they
they
approach it with such such
professionalism
and um hard work
um
so
i sort of see it as it as they're
they're creating something they're
creating they're putting a character
together piece by piece the way a bird
would build a nest or something like
that and i'm there to kind of help them
in whatever way i can but also to like
get to kind of figure them out get on
their page that's a lot of of with me
what what if i have a directing style or
or
process it's like to try to get on the
actor's page and every actor is
different so i may meet them where they
are yeah but so it'll be like i'm doing
one thing with jessica and doing a
different thing with andrew and what
would that a different thing with
vincent d'onofrio i don't know don't
mention just the leads that's fun
working with working with an actor you
know like oh who are you working today
oh vincent afria oh okay sure no big
deal um they're all different they all
have different and you're trying to get
get on their page yeah and figure out
what what what that what that's gonna be
and then um can you remember the
difference if andrew is interested in
andrew andrew is very
i don't want to say this and be wrong
but he's somewhat of a method actor
mm-hmm so he's
kind of in character even when he's not
on camera that must have been he's sort
of has his character with him in a way
so it's not like
you know i used to think method actor
you hear that they're always in
character that literally like if you go
up to them and ask them a question
they'll use the voice of the character
or they'll be like what do you mean yeah
i don't understand yeah yeah no for the
next shot shot
is this the hallelujah show
no we're shooting a movie a documentary
okay we can't do this every time um
it's not that it's more that they don't
drop the character's feelings when
they're not shooting so if the
character's angry
and you if the character is angry or
hurt in some way
or happy even
the actor i my my sense of it is and i
didn't talk to him about this a lot but
my sense of it is he holds on to that
your spidey sense my spidey sense of it
because i didn't want to be like what
are you doing right now
you know like
what are you doing right now what are
you thinking it was more just my vibe
checking it out is he'll keep he'll keep
the feeling very alive he'll keep that
fire burning yeah yeah um
whereas jessica
is more turning it on and off
i see
which is what i certainly do yes and so
before i do a scene i often my co-stars
on the thing i just did would laugh at
me they'd be like all right we're ready
to go and i would just say out loud i'm
angry and
yeah i know it's stupid yeah but i even
think robert de niro oh that's more of a
method guy i guess but like a lot of
actors even if they're not saying i'm
angry they are going like remember
you're you're in a fight you just left
that fight sure or you're disappointed i
mean sometimes in your script it's a lot
of actors they just keep a note keep
notes that say like this is what my
character is thinking in this scene well
i wish i had done that because i was
watching what we shot and i noticed i
was like oh i should have been keeping
like uh
like you're more mad than you were in
the last because you're shooting out of
order and stuff right it's like this
should be your six like you're really
pissed but it was the first thing we
shot so i can tell i'm just kind of like
happy to be on set yeah you know like
that's what um sally field did i did a
movie with with me with sally field and
she we shot it out of order and it's
called hello my name is doris i hope
everyone goes and checks it out on
netflix right now yeah um
she made it i said edit that out i just
want you to be on the joke yeah i didn't
want you to think i was being a dick if
you watch us later
i always do edit that out edit that out
edit that out no uh yeah it's a
wonderful film i i didn't know it was on
netflix it's on netflix that's great it
just came on netflix great yeah it just
came on netflix great um
and uh she would do it did you say
netflix.com
yeah yeah um
she would do yes she sort of made a
chart so she could look at her script at
any moment and her chart could kind of
tell her
where her character needed to be i love
that so that she could almost just like
yeah like reference a piece of paper
that could tell her where where she
needed to get to because so
she had the whole performance kind of
charted out on paper so that she could
just reference the level and are you
doing because i've had directors that do
that and don't do that some of my
favorite directors really no
it's really helpful i know you do
whatever you do but
the ones that make it really easy let's
say go like hey don't forget the scene
before this oh yeah i do that yeah okay
i do that but i don't i don't i don't i
do that but i do that
in the moment so it's like i'll turn to
oh i i absolutely do that but i don't
have it all written down that's all i
meant okay yeah i just don't have it all
written down well i absolutely do that
that it was super helpful don't edit
that out i do that i do that i swear to
god i do that i believe of course but
well but i'm in awe of i'm
i'm in awe of directors like
wes anderson or the guy that did um
ho i think his name is
who did um
parasite i'm in awe of directors who it
appears to me
are
you could if the camera was on me you'd
see my face i was smiling and it started
to fade realizing i had made fun of a
name yeah i thought you were trying to
think of the name of a movie no and then
i was like oh no you can't get that out
you if you maybe you do want to edit
that out well i think it was because it
was earnest i didn't know his name so
you just had like a real moment of me
like but if if you go to the me on the
on my shot
you could see me go
the academy award-winning director and i
was like
like yeah i couldn't do it in a million
years let me it was like this like it
was like there were like bong hits and
you went banger
like that little
if we could have gotten an extreme
close-up we'd have seen a little twitch
happening you would have been in video
village going like god damn it yeah
that's beautiful we got that's beautiful
because
that's the sort of stuff and then i say
circle that circle back circle that
circle yeah and those are the types of
things that i can't yet will i can't
will something so small
well or or just be so
or just be so like
in it that it comes out that you're not
even thinking you trust you you trust
that whatever comes out of you is gonna
be that good yeah yeah yeah so
bong ho and wes anderson and many others
who
you know who i get the feeling that they
plan their movies within an inch of
their lives
their movies are like
blueprinted
yes so
to the to the to the letter with with
music and the shot and how that's all
going to cut together it i'm in awe of
that because to me
what i doing
you know doing even the the stuff i've
done it feels like
just making anything is like so
miraculous forget making it perfectly
precisely to make them to make a movie
like eyes of tammy fan the amount of of
like pieces that need to come together
and the amount of like
x factors that go into it to say nothing
of just like
anything like the script and the actors
in the production of it and you're
trying to make your day and the budget
and there's so many different important
people that who are doing their jobs the
best they can and then to think like
to be one guy getting 200 people to do
it exactly the way you want it
and to even have a vision of exactly the
way you want it because that's the other
part it's like i'm shooting i'm like i
don't know i'm not really sure how this
is going to go you know
i'm just in whole foods getting
attractive looking
ingredients and then i'm and then we're
going to go and we're going to go cook
it but we don't know exactly how we're
going to cook it
[Music]